advice for women dating in their early
20s don't sleep with people right
not unless that is a serious
serious relationship and if you're
hooking up or dating someone and they're
like
yeah i don't really want to get married
just
dump them who cares about that person
like and if you think that you're going
to date them and then change them into
someone who does want to get married
they kind of sound like a loser to begin
with so
welcome to episode 155 of my podcast i
did a q a and a personal life update
which i haven't done in about a year
i hope you enjoy it before we get into
that though today's episode is sponsored
by rabbit air each year since 2009 inc
magazine has consistently rated rabbit
air as one of the fastest growing
companies in the u.s and for good reason
their latest innovation the a3 ultra
quiet air purifier
scene right over there next to my
sexy couch
won the iaf idea good design and the
world's most prestigious red dot design
award thanks to its stylish design and
the advanced filtration technology that
targets airborne allergens particles and
odors effectively
there it is back there squished by my
couch that finally made it to the u.s
it's a good-looking air purifier it's a
good-looking couch the a3 model uses a
six-stage filtration and deodorization
system to maximize air cleanliness in
your home it can cover an area up to one
thousand square feet and filters eight
thousand five hundred and sixty cubic
feet of air every thirty minutes we
breathe in nearly two thousand gallons
of air a day and americans on average
spend 90 percent of their day indoors
air purifiers are necessary in my
opinion when you have animals and
allergies and great for keeping dust
down in your house they make the air
smell better too please do yourself a
favor and visit rabbitair.com today to
see their models or call them 24 7 to
speak to a rabbit air consultant that's
r-a-b-b-i-t-a-i-r-dot-com for access to
the best air purifiers you'll find
anywhere thanks for tuning in and enjoy
this episode let me know if you like the
q a's and i'll do more if you do
remember to hit subscribe if you also
enjoy these i hope you like it
hey guys i'm gonna do a brief update in
a q a i haven't done a q a in about a
year and my life has drastically
improved since my last q a
a lot has happened so i guess i'll start
with
uh
last september i relocated to
tennessee to escape canada because i was
really worried about covid lockdowns and
i was worried that i wasn't going to be
able to travel if i wasn't vaccinated so
i kind of skedaddled i threw away most
of my stuff although
you see the background this showed up
today
my couch has made it finally from canada
which makes me really happy to have some
of my stuff because i literally came to
the us
with two suitcases full of podcast
equipment and that was basically it
so i moved to tennessee and i loved
nashville
but basically as soon as i got there i
got bronchitis and then i just got
bronchitis again and then scarlett was
getting bronchitis and then in december
we both had pneumonia we had to go on
steroids and antibiotics for pneumonia
then i got covered again uh and then
january was healthy for a month
and then scarlett and i both started
getting bronchitis again and it finally
occurred to me was like this hasn't
happened to me since i was in grade five
what's going on i used to get bronchitis
all the time until i was diagnosed with
asthma and it turns out
people with tree allergies shouldn't
live in tennessee
so i got scarlett's allergies tested and
she has tree allergies pretty severely
and uh if you have tree allergies it
makes you susceptible to viral
infections so whenever she got a cold it
would just go into her lungs and she'd
get bronchitis and i was getting
bronchitis so we moved and now i'm in
miami
i love miami there are just palm trees
here
well except in south miami but i'm not
in south miami uh there's a lot of oak
trees there i avoided those i'm a bubble
person what can i say anyway things are
good i'm in miami what else help
happened uh
i got married
so
last august
i met jordan fuller
in austin i went to go explore austin to
see if i wanted to relocate there
uh nashville was kind of a random
decision
one of my friends moved there and she
suggested nashville
and i decided i liked nashville after i
went to austin and saw that there were
just homeless people everywhere there
were tents everywhere and i didn't want
to move from canada in toronto
where i was in a condo downtown and
there were tents outside to austin where
there were also tents outside except the
homeless people were scarier and i've
been back to austin since then and it's
cleaned up and it's a lot better now but
last summer it was in rough shape
anyway i met jordan fuller there and
last summer i was having a pretty rough
time i was
there was a lot of work things going on
but more importantly my dad was still
quite ill with akathesia which is the
worst thing really that can happen to
somebody
i wrote an article about it actually
i'll link it below
he was still quite ill
i was going through a divorce which
wasn't
going terribly but it was still awful
obviously
and i wasn't depressed but i was just
not feeling well and
i met him and he's like i wouldn't say
kind but he's a really really good
person and really stable and
um
he
well i guess i fell in love with him
pretty quickly in austin he showed me
around austin and just pointed out why i
shouldn't live there
and he also
helped me find god i think i wasn't i
talked about this before but i was
always kind of agnostic or
i wasn't an atheist ever i was agnostic
and my dad being my dad
i knew the psychological significance of
the biblical stories but i
they never resonated with me and i
didn't really understand what
not that i do now but i didn't really
understand what god meant or when people
said they had god or they were leaning
on god or god was giving them strength i
was just like that sounds nice but i
don't know what that means
and something hit me last august
and
uh
i just kind of just kind of switched on
one day i was like i uh jordan said how
are you doing funny i married somebody
with my dad's name don't comment on it
there's no meaning behind that it's a
coincidence and purely a coincidence but
he was like how are you doing like how
are you holding up with everything
that's going on and i kind of said well
i'm not depressed but i'm not doing well
i'm pretty unhappy
and he said well you need god and i said
well that's all fine and dandy but i
don't know what that means and i don't
know how to get it and he said ask him
to reveal himself to you and so i went
home and prayed and i prayed because i
was in a really bad place and i was like
anything
i i was like at my lowest point
most of that was his dad was still sick
and i'd spent two years doing primary
care for my dad
and dealing with media
and dealing with online criticism and
trying to figure out what was wrong with
him and how to help him and it just
didn't feel like it was going away
anywhere
and i was sad like heartbroken about
that
um and so i prayed for god to reveal
himself to me and then the next day
a whole bunch of aspects of my life just
kind of got a little bit better they
just turned instead of getting worse
they got better and that was enough for
me and so since then i think because
i've found that uh
and i can lean on that i've felt so much
calmer since last august and things have
just been going really well so i've been
working on
i dropped my podcast from twice a week
to once a week because i was
working
on my dad's brand so i oversee
everything kind of online pr and then
all the social media and podcast and all
the requests that come in and everything
and that is more than a full-time job
i'm working
constantly
that uh and then
i have my podcast obviously going on
hopefully i'm gonna go back to twice a
week actually we've got opposing views i
have uh smart drugs launching soon
which starts with so the company is
called smart drugs and then the first
product is going to be after party which
is a hangover pill so if people weren't
calling me a quack before
they will certainly be calling me a
quack now but
it works just like the diet works the
hangover pills work they're called
dihydromy rice 10 they will be out
shortly um i'll link the website below
so you can sign up if you want to be
notified when they're launching but i've
been using them since i was 20 whenever
i drink i still drink vodka sodas
and i do not drink without them
otherwise
zero carb and alcohol gives you the
worst hangovers known to man so
i don't drink without these guys so i've
been working on that launch and then i
have an electrolytes coming out
and you guys might have
heard about them because i've been
talking about them for like two years
and it's taken that long partly because
of covid and partly because i want them
to be very clean
i had a pretty awful reaction to citric
acid last summer which is in everything
citric acid isn't everything it made me
wired screwed up my skin my face got all
puffy if you look at the podcast from
last summer and i kind of look
like that
it's
because i was drinking electrolytes with
citric acid in them and my body was not
happy with me about that so i had to
redo my electrolytes so that they don't
have citric acid in them
but those are going to be launching in
probably three months probably in the
fall
uh and then i haven't had time to work
on my book in almost a year and i really
need to finish that up and now that my
dad is doing better
much much better thank god i'm gonna
have time to finish up my book but it's
probably gonna take six months because i
have about two years to write still it's
a memoir
i think that's good enough for a
catch-up
i'm gonna get to the q a
exercise routine what is my exercise
routine i haven't exercised in a year
now
i wouldn't recommend that but because i
had bronchitis so much in tennessee i
was exhausted all the time so i didn't
exercise so
yesterday i got this machine because i
can't squat because of my ankle this
beautiful you see this gnarly scar yeah
that's a replaced angle twice replaced
and
it's not great for squatting and
i want to squat so i got this machine
where you kind of like hold on to it and
go up and down
uh and i did that yesterday and i have
sore quads so yesterday's the first time
i exercised in legitimately a year so i
don't have an exercise routine
the reason i am skinny and the only
reason i'm skinny is because of the
diet i'm on lion diet 100 otherwise i
would not be skinny diet update okay so
i am still only eating ruminant meat i
am not dead i'm doing very well i
switched over from i ate like beef and
salt and water for about two years i
have actually switched over so i eat
bison and lamb and i've been doing that
for about two years and
i actually just switched back to beef
because it turns out
i can eat it if it's not aged so most
beef is aged because
some
horrible person decided
aged meat was a good idea it's not it's
not
okay all i eat is meat so if anyone can
say it's a bad idea it's me it's a bad
idea i can't eat it it upsets my stomach
so i found a company that does unaged
beef and now i'm back eating steak which
is amazing actually i can't take credit
for that jordan found a company that
does unaged steak he found me steak
which is great kind of like going out
and hunting and bringing back steak i
haven't had steak in two years so it's
pretty exciting do i have any hidden
talents i do look at this
that's my talent do i have any other
hidden talents i can play piano but not
that well
i'm extremely fast at typing i can
actually type faster than my dad and
he's extremely fast at typing so that's
a hidden talent i guess but i think the
eye is more impressive
you can do that i used to do that if i
was having a conversation with somebody
and i was bored isn't that rude
it's rude how many kids do you want well
i have one and i would probably like
three
or four more i do not enjoy being
pregnant so that's gonna make the whole
thing tricky but i would like three or
four more i think not having kids is a
massive mistake
and i'm fortunate enough and i work hard
enough that i think the next kids i have
um i'll have more help it was pretty
hard with scarlet i was like i literally
had her on my lap and i was working on
my computer at the same time and it
wasn't fun and it was stressful and i
didn't end up getting help until she was
a year old and i didn't have family
around to help mom and dad were on tour
my brother's younger than me
uh so
it wasn't easy uh
and it'll be much easier now
so
three or four i think what are the most
attractive non-physical qualities this
one's fun i think the most attractive
non-physical qualities would be
stability so somebody who's low in
neuroticism uh those are people i think
with men it's even more important
because then women get this feeling of
safety around them if you're around a
neurotic if i'm around a neurotic man
it's just it gives me danger vibes in a
way that is unsettling and like kind of
disgusting so
i would say
the best feature a man can have is being
emotionally stable
and if somebody listening out there
is a neurotic dude diet can help okay
removing inflammatory components of your
diet so your body isn't always angry at
you
can help your neuroticism levels it
lowered mine dramatically my neuroticism
levels used to be at 97th percentile i
got that from my dad's
personality test at understandmyself.com
they were
way up there withdrawal was high
volatility was high neuroticism was high
and when i healed and went on the diet
they lowered and now my withdrawal is
extremely low my volatility is very low
i'm something like 20th percentile in
neuroticism
which means i don't get bothered by very
much and so
having a man that's low in neuroticism
is very attractive uh what else and then
intelligence low in neuroticism and
intelligence and i think you're pretty
much good um ideally having a sense of
humor would be good too but i think if
you find somebody who's smart and not
very neurotic they're probably going to
have a sense of humor do i take any
vitamins or supplements
no the only thing i take occasionally
are unflavored electrolytes which i will
soon be producing and selling uh so i do
use unflavored electrolytes sometimes
and if i drink
i take the hangover pill for sure after
party 100
other than that i don't take any
vitamins or supplements i tried taking
zinc earlier this year because i was
sick with bronchitis and pneumonia
constantly and i was just awake all
night wired i was like who takes zinc
and doesn't sleep me so i don't take
anything i'm very careful with what i
take if i have a headache i will take
tylenol that's about it what was my
favorite unhealthy food
angel food cake angel food cake when i
first went low carb i was having awful
cravings because going low carb was
really hard and i tried to make angel
food cake but i tried to replace all the
ingredients with ingredients i could eat
on my diet so i was like i wasn't eating
eggs so it was like powdered egg
replacement i don't even know what
that's made out of powdered egg
replacement uh coconut flour
uh coconut sugar
it was basically just coconut and it
wasn't very good it turns out it's
really hard to make angel food cake if
you replace all the ingredients with
coconut
but if i had a cheat food if i could
just eat one thing it would probably be
angel food cake which is why earlier i
said if it wasn't for the diet i would
be fat oh
speaking of fat what is my stance on
dad's not beautiful tweets what is my
stance a lot of people were upset by
that and they're like oh people can be
beautiful at any size not really i know
that when i was like i lost a bunch of
weight going low-carb and when i was
overweight i was uglier
and that's just how it is and i think
that's because you're actually healthier
if you're at a healthy weight so what do
i think
um i think that putting your views out
on twitter is a waste of time
but i don't see anything wrong with what
he said it's sports illustrated put on
somebody who's sporty and healthy
and athletic and being like well you can
be athletic if you're 400 pounds
probably you can probably be strong but
you're not healthy objectively so i i
don't know i don't see anything wrong
with most of what my dad does i think
he's a little inflammatory but it's kind
of funny i think it's kind of funny this
episode of the podcast was brought to
you by goldco a leader in the precious
metals industry if you live in the
united states the sponsor has a message
for you the us government wants you to
believe the federal debt is only 31
trillion dollars still a lot of money
they want you to believe that the
national debt is as under control as it
possibly can be but the published number
representing the debt of the u.s is more
than four and a half times lower than
the nation's real debt today the u.s is
over 140 trillion dollars in debt that
includes public debt assets and
liabilities reported in the financial
report of the us government as well as
unfunded social security and medicare
promises
over the course of the average
american's life that could cost them 919
000
inflation and tax hikes seem like the
government's only way out of this dad
and i both have investments in gold it's
a good way to diversify your portfolio
you can call goldco today to see how you
can get paid to protect your retirement
call 866 458-0486
or visit mplikesgold.com
and they'll give you up to ten thousand
dollars in free silver when you open a
qualifying account their better business
bureau score is a plus and now is a good
time to not rely purely on cash that's
866-458-0486 or visit
mplikesgold.com tell them that i sent
you thank you gold co for sponsoring
this episode
and for the potential 10 000 silver
offer enjoy the rest of this episode any
tattoos if not why okay so when i was 14
i got my belly button pierced when i was
16 i had my tongue purist when i was 20
i got my nose pierced and at some point
i had
1 2
3 4 5 6 7 8
9 10 11 12 13 13 13 piercings there's a
lot of piercings i don't have that many
anymore i have my ears though
look at those shine but i don't think
jordan would be impressed if i had my
industrial
like the one that goes across here whoa
backwards here industrial i like that i
thought it was cool i thought it was
cool i might bring it back we'll see but
the reason i don't have a tattoo is
because i drew a tattoo i wanted to get
tattooed because i've got the scarf from
my hip replacement and i was like
already covered in scars who cares if i
have tattoos
and i drew a picture of a dragon and i
put it on my fridge and i was like if i
don't touch this for a month then i'll
get a tattoo and i kept editing it and i
was like well if i want to edit my
tattoo then i probably shouldn't stick
it on my body and that is why i haven't
got a tattoo and now that i'm
30 i probably won't get a tattoo yep no
i'm probably not going to get a tattoo
or any more piercings but i am going to
keep these guys i like these if
everybody stops sneezing how long would
it take for you to notice possibly years
it i might die without noticing so i
don't actually go out very often
um i i was talking to jordan about this
yesterday i used to at least go out and
i probably drank too much honestly but i
used to go out and drink and that was my
kind of relax after a long week go out
and drink with some friends
and for the last year it's been like
non-stop work
seriously non-stop my dad signed on with
daily wire and jordan and i did a lot of
the leg work behind that so that was
that was a lot of work for months and
months and months and growing brands is
actually hard i i think people are
understanding that more
you know a couple of years ago it was oh
you have a social media phone and you
don't do anything other than take
selfies all day that is not true social
media is basically just marketing so you
have to learn how to market
uh so i've been doing that and i i love
working i'm i love working
if i'm not working i would go crazy if i
couldn't work so i've basically been
working uh and one of the things i like
about jordan 2 is he works
really hard all the time too and that's
really fun so we can work together but
basically nine until
basically nine or ten at night um i'm
working so that's answering emails or
pushing things forward
one of the
huge things that i'm working on that
will do this big launch but i'll tell
you guys first anyway
peterson academy which is so much fun
and that's taking up a huge chunk of my
time
um so we're contacting professors from
around the world um we got a studio in
miami to film six to eight hour
courses we're going to offer
accreditation through peterson academy
we're trying to
become the first online university
that's teaching actual material
we'll start with liberal arts degrees
and then move into marketing and
business
after launch which we are planning for
next february
we have an app in development it's going
to be like a subscription site so you
can log in and you can get access to all
the content
it's going to be epic
epic and so that's taking up a ton of my
time but that's super fun i don't
remember where i was going with that but
that's another fun project actually i'll
link that below too so i have a bunch of
things linked below smart drugs but
peterson academy is the big one that i'm
excited about advice for women dating in
their early 20s don't sleep with people
right
not unless that is a serious serious
relationship and
if you're
hooking up or dating someone and they're
like
yeah i don't really want to get married
just
dump them who cares about that person
like and if you think that you're going
to date them and then change them into
someone who does want to get married
they kind of sound like a loser to begin
with so get rid of that person that or
like sit them down and have a very
serious conversation and
ask questions like do you ever want to
get married okay well if you do when do
you want to get married and make sure
that your dreams align with their dreams
because if you're dating somebody and
they don't have any plan on getting
married then you're wasting your time
and
that's trickier for women because women
are
most attractive and most fertile when
they're young
and men i would say get more attractive
you know in their mid 30s maybe even 40s
and they get richer so
they have time that you don't have so
make sure the person that you're with
has the same kind of goals as you don't
just sleep around it doesn't help you
and don't be ashamed of actually talking
about what you want if you want to get
married and you want to have kids
there's absolutely nothing wrong with
that and for some reason society at the
moment is telling young women that they
should just sleep around and work in
well into their 30s because having kids
forever is easy uh don't worry like
science has caught us up so you can have
kids whenever you want which
fortunately there are ways to have kids
and extend the period of time you can
have kids but some people aren't that
lucky and you don't know if you're one
of those people but
it's totally fine to talk to someone and
say hey i do want to get married i do
want to have kids that's healthy and any
sane man would be attracted to that
so don't just
go with the flow which is at least when
i was in university which is
parties sleep around
and dampen down you know long-term goals
and i think it's also easier when you
get a bit older to differentiate between
who actually is smart and has it
together and who doesn't
i had a very difficult time when i was
in my early 20s figuring out who was
smart and who wasn't smart i think
that's my advice is for relationships
try to find somebody who aligns and
honestly if you're in university and you
can't find any guy who
doesn't suck
maybe go to church that might be a way
to do it people with christian values
are pretty
solid people it's probably a
controversial thing to say
go fishing for a husband at church but
it might be a good idea ooh this is fun
when should the guy get married before
or after getting his career on track i
think it totally depends on who you meet
you don't want to meet the girl of your
dreams and then think well i have to get
my career on track and i know there are
a lot of red pill people out there that
are like just wait wait till your
mid-thirties get your career on track
make all your money then hook up with a
23 year old because they're most fertile
at 23.
but if you find somebody you like i'm
not entirely sure who i was imitating
there if you find somebody you like then
just marry them because
marrying somebody and getting that
relationship
organized in your life
can
excel your career right if you have
someone there to help you that can
actually
help your work life
and then
like role reversing i work with my
husband so it's a bit different but
being in a stable relationship with
somebody who's who helps me has made me
ten times more productive and i've made
him more productive so i think if you
find the right person it can help excel
your career so i wouldn't put off
marriage
um
but i would you know focusing on work as
a dude i think isn't a bad idea focusing
on work as a girl either i mean i like
working all the time all those people
online really that say i i don't agree i
don't agree with people that put women
in a category that's like okay
you should be staying at home and having
kids and i know a lot of women who do
want to stay home and have kids
which is totally fine and if you do that
is healthy and you shouldn't be ashamed
of it but if you don't want to stay home
and have kids you also shouldn't be
ashamed of that i i know that if i
just stayed home and had kids i would go
bat [ __ ] so fast so fast
it'd be like six months and i'd be crazy
so i think try and try and envision the
life that you want and make that happen
right and i wouldn't you know keep
your dreams small
i think you can dream up whatever you
want right and who says you can't have
that who like why is it that some people
become billionaires or start companies
and some people have yachts some people
achieve these things or have
you know five kids some people achieve
these things so why couldn't that be you
right so
dream up however you want your life to
be and then
assume that that can happen and work
your way towards it right i think that
the glass ceilings that exist we just
put in place ourselves who do you hope
to be in five years ooh okay five years
i would like
two or three more kids two or three more
kids i would like to
have launched peterson academy
i would like that to be the most
successful online education platform i
would i would like to have published my
book at least five years away that's way
too far i'd like to have published my
book i'd like to have a guide out for
people trying to start the lion diet
to help people with autoimmune disorders
and
a yacht would be nice if i had to have a
goal i would like a yacht i would also
like to never fly
commercial again i hate flying
commercial
flying commercial is awful everything
about airports is awful and kovit made
it worse i think a quarter of the times
i flew a lot this year because dad was
on tour and i was opening for some of
his shows so there was a lot of flying
around and i swear
one out of four flights was delayed to
the next day to the next day like oh you
have to be somewhere today nah we missed
a wedding this year because of that so
i want to make enough money so that i
can fly private plus then i can
contribute to global warming and make
everyone a little bit angrier at me does
your father want to adopt a child i want
to be his son dad has enough to deal
with with me
so i'm going to go with no would you
consider homeschooling so i found a
school that looks pretty sweet uh in
miami for scarlet it looks pretty sweet
they teach programming to
kindergarteners
and there's a whole bunch of tortoises
they've got a boat like it is extra
there's a swimming pool outside it looks
like a dream compared to the public
schools i went to which were
were shifty to say the least like
we had the ravine behind my high school
where people just did ketamine and i
thought that was normal
like people don't just do cocaine in
high school ketamine
someone got stabbed and i literally
thought that was normal i don't know if
i'd change it it was an art school too
so that was fun but anyway i would
rather that scarlett doesn't go to that
kind of school
so
i think and i hope that i found a good
school here she starts kindergarten
in august
but if it does end up being
ideologically possessed and they start
shoving garbage down scarlett's throat
then i will pull her out and if i can't
find a non-ideologically possessed
school
although i'm hoping there are some
because this is florida
i'll be at miami if i can't find some
then i'll probably hire a private
teacher i wouldn't consider
homeschooling done by myself because
i have too much work to do and i'm not
interested in homeschooling kids i don't
have the patience for it and i wouldn't
do a good job i've been teaching
scarlett how to read over the summer but
that's like 15 minutes a day and i think
that's really valuable time that i spend
with her there is no way i could
tolerate doing that for
hours all day plus i want to build my
brand and finish my book and build dad's
brand and peterson academy which is the
big one put out products so
yeah i would consider homeschooling but
i wouldn't be the one doing the
homeschooling what is your middle name
my middle name my full name is michaela
alexis
roberts which is my mom's last name
peterson fuller
ah
funny story
okay so when we went to get the marriage
license
i was not exactly
i was excited right and nervous
and jordan filled out the marriage
certificate for me and he put
michaela alexis
roberts fuller
because i said yes i'll take your last
name i respect him i want his last name
i now have his last name but i got out i
signed everything we leave and i was
like wait a minute is it michaela alexis
roberts-peterson fuller he was like no
it's michaela alexis roberts fuller and
i like sat down outside on the concrete
and was like
okay i didn't agree to get rid of
peterson though i didn't agree to get
rid of peterson
okay okay just let me sit here just let
me sit here for a little just let me sit
here and so he kind of walked away and
then i felt bad because he was expecting
to help me be all excited but i was like
no it's like
i'm i was like 30 i'm 30 this is
this is my name
i had a little angsty moment uh so right
now i'm keeping peterson for social
media because i want to be
searchable online um but i am using
fuller in day-to-day
life which is fun michaela fuller
that was a funny story i did freak out
but then but then i was happy about it
realistically plus i really wouldn't
want to marry someone who wasn't like
take my last name
said like oh you can do whatever you
want darling like nah have you looked
into the impact of botox on autoimmune
conditions and food sensitivities so i
get botox and i don't have any
autoimmune symptoms on the diet and i
don't get flare-ups from botox so that's
one person it's literally a toxin that
freezes your muscle a bit so i wouldn't
say it's
something to do that's healthy but i
started getting it right here when i was
23
because i was
i'd been
chronically horribly depressed for my
entire life and i had these
frown lines that were just crazy and it
used to be my go-to expression which was
like if i was thinking about something
i'd frown and at one point my mom was
like you should get botox because it
might like relax your forehead and i got
botox and it was
such a relief it was such a relief to
not be glaring all the time which i'm
sure affects your serotonin levels so i
started getting botox when i was 23 but
i mean i'm 30 now
so yeah i get botox anybody who doesn't
want to be wrinkly gets botox and it
doesn't flare up my autoimmunity so i'm
happy with it would you ever do a
podcast with your husband 100 yes we
have
in the living room instead of a dining
room table we decided just to put a sofa
and a couple of chairs to set it up as a
podcast studio but we just moved in here
so it's not set up yet but he is going
to be my first guest
i'm excited what's the most important
lesson you've learned about
relationships go with your gut seriously
i used to
i used to not listen to
my gut at all right i'd get bad vibes
from people and i'd think well there's
no reason for me to feel that way let's
just ignore it don't ignore that just go
with it it's probably your brain picking
up on cues that you can articulate
and then giving you the answer
and so go with your gut if you find
somebody and they make you feel safe and
calm
that's the right person if you find
someone and they freak you out
doesn't matter
nothing else matters right if they freak
you out on a level avoid that did you
have times when life was so difficult
and you had no support and everything
seemed meaningless i'm definitely had
times that were very difficult and i
felt like i had no support and i felt
like everybody was against me
i don't think i had points where things
felt meaningless i always felt like i
always felt like there was something
more almost so
what kept me going through it was
determination and
and anger and kind of like looking at my
life
as a narrative and thinking
i'm not letting it go this way this
isn't how it ends this isn't how my
story goes i'm changing this no matter
what so i did definitely had times in my
life like that i had years like that my
entire life was like that i would say
until very very recently with all the
chronic illness and and the way i got
through it was being stubborn and
thinking i'm changing this no matter
what this is not how my life goes right
waking up every morning even if i felt
like i was in hell
thinking
one more day one more day i can do one
more day i can do one more month i can
do one more year and i'm going to get
through this and at some point things
are going to change i can feel that
they're going to change and they did
change which is great because
things were really bad for quite a while
and i think you can see that if you look
at my old podcasts i mean i started my
podcast when my dad was in the hospital
in serbia
and
it just killed me like i started the
podcast because
it kind of helped me escape right so i
was spending a lot of time at the
hospital and i was doing primary care
and the podcast was like i could have an
hour conversation with somebody who
wasn't in the hell that was my life
and i
it was a bit of an escape but i was like
for a lot of the episodes a lot of the
episodes i was crying before i started
the episode
so like sweeping
and then turn on the camera and start an
episode it was rough but things are
great right now how similar and
different are you and your husband on
the fig five aspects we're almost
identical but his agreeableness is like
zero like if his conscientiousness
levels weren't at 99th percentile i
would be very concerned i told him
earlier it was like fortunate that he
had god because
his personality
his agreeableness it's it's scary
but other than that we're almost
identical on all the aspects which i
think is really nice so we're both super
extroverted
hyper conscientious
i'm more open than him although who
knows how much my past with psychedelics
has played into that although an open
person is probably more inclined to take
psychedelics so
uh that and then neuroticism he's he's
like zero in neuroticism i'm a little
bit more neurotic but
still very very low
and then agreeableness i i scored zero
in politeness zero
which i think is really good for doing
more business oriented stuff in
negotiating but my compassion i think i
was 89
so
it kind of skewed me to average-ish
agreeableness he his he scored zero in
compassion
like a lizard tips for self-confidence
this person works out eats healthy and
looks good but is still not confident i
would say do more things
i didn't get confident in my abilities
until
i had done more things right you're not
going to be if you're a 24 year old 25
year old 26 year old
and you just graduated from university
and you're in your first job and you're
not confident you probably shouldn't be
confident because you haven't actually
done anything
right um i've been
working
for my dad since 2018 full time so
that's getting to be four years and i've
been running a lot
of business operations and finance and
taxes and because i've been doing that i
think it was only really this year that
i was like you know what i'm actually
pretty good at this right and that was
only after
talking to hundreds of business people
and seeing how they work and seeing how
i work
so i probably wasn't particularly
confident until i was like 29 or 30 and
that's because i'd been working
full-time for a really long time and i'd
accomplished a lot so i think it's
reasonable not to be self-confident
until you've spent a number of years
working on something and you're actually
kind of good at it right um i think it's
good not to be too hard on yourself so
if you're beating yourself down
but you actually haven't had time to go
out and do things like give yourself a
break there but and then if you already
are
30 and you're still not self-confident
i'd say go out and do more things
and if you're still not confident after
that i would say what's your definition
of eating healthy and probably make sure
you're not eating any type of garbage
because maybe it's impacting your
neuroticism levels worst day slash best
day you've had this year okay worst day
uh okay the worst day was my mom texted
me and my dad's acatheia had come back
and i
was already on a plane over to see him
and
that was the worst day for sure he's
doing fantastic by the way
um but that was just awful so that was
the worst day and
the best day
jordan
fuller do i have to say that i call my
dad dad okay we're just gonna call
jordan fuller jordan can't be calling
him fuller jordan f
anyway um two weeks after we met two
weeks after we met he told me he wanted
to marry me and i almost had a heart
attack
because one it was two weeks that was
the main reason and two i had kind of
put myself into this basket of people
that were going to have a very very very
difficult time
finding somebody or getting married
again because i'm extremely disagreeable
and
if i'm with somebody
i can usually bowl them over and i've
had this issue for my entire life so i
end up with a man that's generally
speaking more agreeable than me and then
it just doesn't work because
we'll be having a discussion and then
i'll say something and his feelings will
get hurt and i'll be like
okay it's so unattractive to have a
normal discussion with a man and then
have their feelings get hurt
when i'm not trying to hurt anyone's
feelings when it's like
that wasn't i like can't be walking
around on eggshells
and so i was worried i wasn't going to
be able to find somebody that i could
actually communicate with fortunately i
found somebody who scored zero
percentile in agreeableness so it's been
working out pretty well but i think he
told me he wanted to marry me and i said
okay
are you sure though because one it's
only been two weeks you have no idea who
i am
um two i have a kid three i'm still in
the middle of divorce that's been going
on for like four years
um four i work all the time okay and i'm
not going to stop working all the time
there were just a whole bunch of things
i was like are you sure because you
can't be sure you can't be serious um
but that was probably the best day this
year i think that even trumps
wedding day i like i was shocked i was
shocked for like three days like this
man cannot be real and then i think i'm
gonna finish up this q a with a cute
story so the other day scarlett
scarlet's in bed and she goes
did you tell jordan you had a kid um
before you guys met and i was like yeah
of course jordan knew about you i wasn't
gonna keep you a secret and then be like
hey surprise here's a kid
and
and she was like oh and i was like why
she goes
oh
well it would have been more fun if it
was a surprise
and i was like that is
so cute that is so cute that that's the
way that she was thinking about it
that's like what's wrong with having a
kid look at me i'm a cute little
four-year-old
so i thought that was cute that was the
other day
anyway
that was a bunch of questions a little
bit rambly perhaps but i hope you guys
enjoyed thank you so much for the
support and watching the channel i'm
hoping to go back to two podcast
episodes a week hopefully some of those
are in person i'm gonna do more opposing
views uh there's one on drag shows
coming up
which should be
quite interesting
but yeah thanks for the support